machen wir mal ketchup auf die hieß es
geht mir ist langweilig irgendwie habe
ich die letzten tage überhaupt nichts zu
tun
jetzt wieder diese herbstsaison anfängt
ich mich wieder an mützen gewöhnen aber
ich habe einen grässlichen eierkopf in
münsters unbeschreiblich also ja ich
habe folgendes problem ich habe viel zu
viel freizeit in den letzten tagen um
genau zu sein nur freie zeit und
irgendwie nutze ich sie nicht so richtig
deshalb dachte ich mir ich habe ja die
letzten tage habe ich keine videos
gemacht obwohl ich halt so viel freizeit
hatte was mehrere gründe hat zum
beispiel das ich vor allem video ideen
habe wo ich einfach gerne jemand anders
dabei habe sei es sebastian sagt luca
oder wer auch immer einfach weil es
irgendwie cooler ist zurzeit aber ich
dachte mir heute heißt du mal drauf
macht aber so ein bunt zusammengemischt
das video und nimmst auf jeden fall
wasser und das mache ich jetzt gerade
dich glaubst du mein größtes problem ist
dass wir keinen plan machen übrigens
wahrscheinlich habt ihr auch das video
geklickt wegen dem titel und im titel
steht ja ketchup auch dieses oder so das
mache ich gleich weil ich habe mir so
ein krasses protection ding für die
schule geholt und angeblich kann man das
frühwerk drauf machen
ich bin richtig gespannt ich vertrage
ganze sache aber ich bin viel zu
neugierig uns nicht auszutesten und auch
wenn jetzt schon wieder die sie im titel
steht musste das einfach austesten weil
wenn es dann schief geht habe ich
nächstes ein video darüber gemacht
also ja das hauptproblem bei mir ist
ohne plan in den tag zu gehen und ist
das tödlich wirklich glaube so wird es
vielen von euch auch gehen aber wenn ihr
aufwacht und nicht irgendwie die schule
müsste oder so sondern aufwacht und erst
mal kurz youtube checkt und dann einfach
den ganzen tag auf so was hängen bleibt
das ist grässlich wenn du dich von
morgens früh an quasi in diesem keller
modus befindet und videos kooks und
facebook twitter sonst was irgendwie
braucht ist das problem ja dass du nicht
kreativ wirst wie fällt nicht ein was
für ein video machen kannst und das ist
absolut mies weil eigentlich so
ihr habt ja mitbekommen meine ansage ist
es ganz eine schwester mal zum
geburtstag bekommt kann man das ganze
hier ist es das ist meine schwester ich
bin froh dass ganz ist okay also ich
sagen wollt ihr habt ja allem eine große
ankündigung mitbekommen
nach dem abi geht's los und so ist es ja
nicht so wirklich also klar ich hab ich
finde jetzt ich mache jetzt konnte und
bei denen ich mich selbst wohler fühle
aber das große problem ist irgendwie
nach wie vor dass ich nicht so wirklich
regelmäßig bin und warum ich dachte dass
das nach dem abi anders wird ich wollte
eigentlich rasch nach dem abi nach köln
ziehen und dann wäre ich ja quasi
dauerhaft umgeben von seiner kreativen
atmosphäre so stelle ich mir zumindest
vor so zum beispiel dass ich mich oft
mit luka treffen wir zusammen videos
machen irgendwie habe ich das bisher
noch nicht so wirklich hinbekommen und
ich glaube es wäre richtig wenn ich das
weitermache aber andererseits fest mir
ein bisschen schwer so von meiner
familie weg zu gehen weil die freuen
sich natürlich dass ich noch da bin und
so aber ich glaube das werde ich bald
mal machen ich will es nicht aussprechen
dass es dann besser wird oder sonst was
aber so stelle ich mir zumindest vorn
okay ich hoffe mal ich konnte das
irgendwie ein bisschen zusammenschneiden
das sollte eigentlich schon alles
durcheinander video sein wo ich mehrere
lustige sachen nach und ein bisschen
aber okay da kommen wir zu dem grund
weshalb wahrscheinlich die meisten von
euch hier auf video geklickt haben tun
übrigens leid dass ich nicht komplett
darum ging aber ich habe ja schon
erklärt so ich wollte heute halt einfach
ein video machen und einfach nur ein
video über sachen auf die sie schützen
wollte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt machen
kommen wir zur sache also es geht schon
wieder um die hier das heißt schon
wieder das video ist ja ewig her
aber ja ich habe
die schuhe mit so einem spray behandelt
und ich habe schon mehrfach gesehen dass
man angeblich nach nachdem man es drauf
gemacht hat alles mögliche mit seinen
schuhen anstellen kann also wir
probieren spiel steigern das ganze mal
bis hin mit wasser erst mal zu gucken
wie das abgewiesen wird treiben ist auf
die spitze mit ketchup also ich mach es
ist so bescheuert diese 800 euro schule
mache ich ketchup ok mit wasser ist es
ja kein großes ding ich meine schule
werden so oder so meiners und das müssen
auch jesus acht rennen also machen wir
wasser an und halten ihn schon runter
okay das ist richtig cool also gut
imprägnierte schon jetzt das wasser drin
das ist nicht wirklich schlechte kritik
nicht nur hole ich sie gar nicht
verdienen
sag ich mal wie andere leute die viel
mehrheiten ist meist um ist damit wieder
das perlt einfach zu cool weg das ist
richtig fassen wir sind die schule
wieder staubtrocken das ist echt cool
aber ja kommen wir zum eigentlichen test
zum härtetest mit catcher und ich
probiere bin echt sauer blöd dass ich es
mache aber machen wir mal ketchup auf
die hieß the prestige ist dass es nicht
klappt ich meine das ist schon ein
extremer wertverlust aber wenn ich die
aufgeregt energie kommt wenn dann
richtig will ich sagen also dort wir
haben jetzt catch up on mars auf dem
schuh man guckt euch das mal an und wir
probieren sie es aus
ob und wie es ab geht s richtig ist aber
dass nicht ab ich probiere es erstmal so
runter zu stark wow leuten da ist nichts
also nicht da sind so 12 drückt man da
sind so ein paar mini kleine pünktchen
hier so ich weiß nicht ob man die sieht
also das sind so die sind wirklich
mikroskopisch klein und ansonsten ist
nichts und wenn wir so eine waffe
darüber machen
das sind auch die weg war okay das ist
stupid nahes leute ok kennt machen wir
mal den härtetest okay leute ihr seht es
da ist echt viel zeug drauf wir
probieren es mal aus es fehlt einfach ab
und das was nicht direkt abfällt wie
hier an der seite kannst du einfach mit
ein bisschen wasser komplett restlos weg
machen und jetzt ist wieder als neue
games an
ich habe echt schiss dass das nicht
funktioniert und ich den schufa und den
zu ruinieren
aber es hat geklappt ich bin happy ich
kann jetzt in zukunft ketchup auf die
schule machen und falls ihr euch fragt
warum ich das gemacht habe weiß einfach
verdammt cooles oder findet ihr es nicht
weiß wie das einfach runter fällt von
dem schuh findet im flugzeug geholt
beide schuhe sind komplett unversehrt
dass er ist der erste häftling auf dem
weil er sowieso nur wasser drauf und der
zweite hier auch komplett clean
übrigens macht ihr das auch so wenn ihr
schon auf ganz neue habt dass ihr tier
einfach im haus trat sowieso de von
unten noch noch komplett clean ist
ich mache das immer erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch an luca für seine zwei
millionen abonnenten
es war knapp für mich so ein bisschen
genötigt was zu dem video von neapel
wasser über luca gemacht habe zu sagen
ich will das gar nicht groß drauf
eingehen und fand so einige sachen so
kontrovers ich meine er hat irgendwie
zum beispiel gesagt ja warum kritisierst
du mich für das baden in chicken wings
video warum reden die leute immer noch
drüber also was ich dazu sagen kann das
video ist noch online
mein mann hat bei youtube die
möglichkeit videos auf privat zu stellen
oder so nach wie vor kriegen leute die
das ohne kontext sehen einfach ein
schlechtes bild von dir vermittelt
beziehungsweise lernen oder sehen ist es
ja voll fanny
in lebensmitteln zu bauen und von daher
bin ich das argument einfach nicht nicht
wirklich in ordnung zu sagen hey ich
habe mich dafür entschuldigt und ich
weiß auch nicht ob das video
metallisierte ich habs grad mal getestet
ich habe keine werbung bekommen hat sich
drauf geklickt habe aber falls es noch
mal interessiert sein sollte oder falls
man falls es mal arisiert sein sollte
und du es noch online lässt dann ist das
sehr wohl mega mega kontrovers sozusagen
ich habe mich entschuldigt aber es ist
nur online neue leute können es sehen
und ich krieg geld dafür wenn ich es
wenn sich leute anschauen also mein
ansonsten war das ja eher so eine
oberflächliche argumentation zu sagen
eltern content ist selber scheiße
content liegt immer im auge des
betrachters und daher kann man sich da
nicht irgendwie großartig sonst
einmischen aber so dass der lukas stück
scheiße bezeichnet hat und so ist halt
auch wieder na ja wie soll ich sagen das
ist halt zeug nicht so von von einem
großartigen niveau zur leute ich bin
sehr gespannt ich hab fragen und was
auch immer bekommen und ich gucke jetzt
mal ob ich noch ein paar coole fragen
bekommen habe weil wie gesagt die erste
fand ich jetzt nicht so gut
also schauen wir mal absolut cool dass
da irgendwas kurz gesprochen okay hier
ist eine frage wie finde ich ganz
interessant und zwar wird gefragt was
hältst du davon zuschauer für ein foto
auf die wange zu küssen
die antwort ist absolut überhaupt nicht
ich finde es auch eigentlich schon
ziemlich komisch wenn ich zum beispiel
nach umarmung fotos oder sowas gefragt
wird weil die die leute die dann danach
fragen wollen irgendwie auf dem foto
sondern ehe festhalten die aber
eigentlich gar nicht existiert also
davon habe ich überhaupt nichts klar
fragt likes to fanpage bilder deshalb in
letzter zeit ziemlich wenig getan
eigentlich will ich gern mal wieder
öfter machen einfach so die die bindung
stärker werden zu lassen mal wieder weil
irgendwie dadurch dass ich nicht mehr so
regelmäßig videos mache und nicht so
aktiv bin auf soziale medien habe so das
gefühl dass wir auch so ein bisschen
entfremdet haben
zuschauer zu schauen ich irgendwie würde
ich das gerne wieder anders haben also
ich glaube ich werde mich mal wieder
aktiver irgendwann war damit so ein
bisschen aufgehört aber aber das wird
sich jetzt ändern
ich gehe jetzt sogar sofort auf
instagram und werde mal ein paar fotos
michael pokorny mumma gut die kenne ich
die seite argumentiert für viele
leiharbeiter kürzer in wurde ich
gebastelt dafür dass ich ihn nominiert
bin dass er richtig lustig wird richtig
google vergleich vielleicht soll ich das
echt öfter mal brausen gibt es
eigentlich noch youtuber mit deiner
meinung nach guten content bezogen auf
youtube deutschland glaube die frage
kommt weil ich mich in den letzten
videos häufig negativ geäußert habe und
ja es gibt dabei mit gutem content gucke
gerne die blogs von casey leistet aber
ansonsten mag ich gerne auf youtube.com
watch hat mich sogar zurück hat mich
sogar zurück abonniert als ihn damals
abonniert hat page create music week und
zu aber das kannst du eigentlich meine
meine lieblings youtube machen keinen
deutschen content deutschen content aber
auch öfters mal aber da habe ich keinen
keine person die ich so verfolge sondern
quicklebendig ein video interessant
findet hast du keine lust mehr auf
youtube werde ich gefragt die ich kann
nicht verstehen weil ich so wenig videos
machen aber wie ich am anfang schon
gesagt habe ist eigentlich dieser
müssiggang
der grund dafür ich habe im gegenteil
ich hab eigentlich voll bock auf youtube
ich liebe es eine coole video idee zu
haben sie umzusetzen und dann belohnt zu
werden indem sie hilft gut ankommt war
so also keinesfalls habe ich keine lust
mehr auf youtube okay letzte frage
würdest du lieber dein ganzes leben nur
einen song hören oder jeden song einmal
lieber jedem song nur einmal weil ich
meine es ist viel mehr wert
neue sachen zu entdecken oder zumindest
die möglichkeit zu haben
das aber eigentlich echt ne coole frage
ja und ich würde sagen das war's dann
vom heutigen video
wir sehen uns dann nicht mal um